- I feel like everybody at some point
in their life has met somebody
who was truly inspiring.
They seem to have their life figured out.
They are determined.
They can carve out their own destiny.
They create their own luck.
And on the flip side, a lot
of us have met people who seem
to just bury themselves in a hole
and are unable to get out of it.
They are unable to
recognize the opportunities
in front of them,
they harbor a lot of
negativity towards life
and they seem perpetually stuck.
Helpless against seemingly
endless negative external forces.
And I feel like a lot of people
talk about these two types
of people and try to
distill one single belief
or concept that separates the two of them.
And if you just adopt this belief
then you'll be like the successful person
and not like the unsuccessful person.
But I feel like it's a
little foolish to do so
because everybody's life is
so well wildly different.
People had different upbringings.
People have such different
instilled beliefs
about the world or religion or whatever.
It's hard to just say
that one single belief
will change someone's life
for the better for eternity
and they'll never
experience hardship again.
But I have noticed one trait
that successful people seem
to share more often than
unsuccessful people.
And I can't help but think that there
is a strong correlation
between having that belief
and having success in life.
And that is that successful
people tend to have
an internal locus of control.
And less successful people
tend to have an external one.
So what is locus of control?
Locus of control is the degree
to which people believe that they,
as opposed to external forces,
have control over the outcome
of events in their lives.
So, you watching this
right now either have
an external locus of control
or an internal locus of control.
And I think the severity
of either of these extremes
was formed through your
childhood and your development
and your transition into adulthood.
Because children, very
young children especially,
have an extra internal locus of control.
External forces have
control over the outcomes
of events in their lives.
When you're a kid,
you're pretty much absolutely helpless,
especially when you're a very young kid.
You can't really feed
yourself, or clothe yourself.
You're so dependent on a
parental figure to provide you
with all of your needs that
you basically have no choice
but to develop a very
external locus of control.
The situations of your life are
entirely out of your control
and you're entirely dependent
on some sort of third party
to provide you with what
you need to survive.
And there's nothing wrong with that,
like, kids don't really have a choice
in the matter, that is their world.
That's a factual and realistic
belief to have as a kid.
But hopefully you had a
competent parental figure
or a leader as you're growing up
that kind of taught you the
ropes, how to, how to clean,
how to make money, how to fend
for yourself in the world.
I've always thought that if a
parent does their job right,
they basically phase themselves out.
Hopefully by the time you're an adult,
you still want your parents around,
but you don't need them around.
If they were to die, you'd be okay.
Like you could fend for yourself.
You can figure stuff out.
But unfortunately for a lot of us,
we bring a lot of the helplessness
of childhood into adulthood.
We never shake the idea that we need
to be provided for somehow.
We remain dependent on some
sort of external system
to provide us with the necessary materials
to survive and thrive.
And a lot of the time this
is really hard to spot.
From an occupational standpoint,
sometimes this can look like
being unsatisfied with your job
and you're working so hard
but getting paid so little.
So you externalize the
struggle onto your boss
or your provider and you blame
him for your life's problems.
My life sucks because my boss
doesn't see how much I'm worth
and he's not paying me enough money.
Or you might look at
the government and say,
the government is not giving
me the proper tax breaks
that I need in my societal class
and it's making it really hard for me.
And the tricky thing is
that a lot of the time,
these are valid complaints.
There's a certain amount of logic to them.
But the default shouldn't
be to place all of the blame
and place all of the responsibility
for changing the outcome
of your life onto these external forces,
otherwise we will just be imprisoned
by them for our entire lives.
Our default should be to look
at the cards that we are given
and take full responsibility
for how we play those cards.
I feel like having this
internal locus of control
it's extremely important
in today's day and age
because obviously in 2020
we were just hit with a global pandemic
and so much of that felt
so far out of our control
that it was very tempting.
I know for me personally
it was to develop a feeling
of helplessness almost,
that childlike helplessness
started to blossom again.
And I felt like I had to
put my entire life on hold,
put all my habits on hold
until this whole pandemic blew over.
Sometime halfway through I realized
that I can work within this system.
There are things that I can do to improve
my life despite the crappy situation.
And it is my sole
responsibility to figure out how
to thrive within the environment
that I've been placed.
It's nobody's responsibility
to come be your night
and shining armor and fight
the dragons in your life.
It's only your responsibility.
And I don't want this to come
across like I'm scolding you,
like, the father you never had.
No, I'm just kidding.
But hopefully to empower you.
Once you start adopting more of
an internal locus of control,
it'll start to feel a lot less
like life is happening to you
but it will start to
feel a lot more like life
is happening due to you.
And that's a very
empowering belief to have.
In fact, I would say it's a prerequisite
to making any sort of
substantial change in your life.
Your positive actions
to work your way out of
a bad situation, do have an impact.
Your efforts are not in vain.
Because not only do you have
the power to change your life,
you're the only one who does.
Videos like these are made possible.
Thanks to amazing
sponsors like Skillshare.
I actually recently just bought
a kind of expensive piano
and I did this so that I
would have no excuse not
to get better at jazz improv.
Probably not the best use of my money,
but I couldn't resist.
Unfortunately, due to the
pandemic it's really hard
to find in-person classes right now.
Thankfully Skillshare is
kind of the next best thing.
And Charles Cornell, a YouTuber
that you guys might know,
has an amazing improvisational
piano class on Skillshare.
So I'm diving headfirst
into that and I'm learning
a lot of new things and
I get to use that piano,
and it's just a win-win.
For those of you who don't know,
Skillshare is an online learning community
with thousands of classes,
covering dozens of topics.
Everything from music
lessons, to photography
and videography, to the
culinary arts and productivity.
No matter what you're into
or what you want to learn,
Skillshare probably has a class for it.
And chances are, it's also very practical
because all the classes
on Skillshare are designed for real life.
It's super easy to take
whatever you're learning
on Skillshare and apply it directly
to your real life pursuits.
Not only is it such a useful tool,
but it's also extremely affordable.
If you get the annual membership,
it comes in at less than $10 a month.
So it's kind of a no brainer.
And the first a thousand
of you who clicked the link
in the description below,
will get a free trial
of a Skillshare premium membership.
So in like less than two minutes,
you can be diving into your
first class on Skillshare using
the amazing offer down below.
Learn something new,
explore your creativity,
and as usual, have a great time.
Oh, Hey, if you liked this video,
make sure that you hit Like
because when you hit Like,
the algorithm blesses me and
it shoves my very bald head
cause I just baked it today.
Shoves my bald head into
other people's homepages,
helping them out.
And it also helps me out.
So it's kind of a win-win for everybody.
If you're lurking here and
this is the thousandth time
that you've seen my face,
and this is the thousand times
consider subscribing and
hitting the bell icon,
so that the next time I upload
a new video you get notified.
Actually, no, we don't need
more notifications in our life.
Just like, hit the bell icon
if you really want to get notified,
but, hell get off the notification train,
free yourself from this
algorithmic living.
And don't hit the bell icon.
If you hit the bell icon and
hit it, that's a bold move,
but I don't know, I feel
like the algorithm probably
will still serve you the video.
Anyways, I'm not going crazy.
You're going crazy.
Catch you the next video.
It's going to be really,
really quick within the
next few days, actually.
And it's gonna feature a special guest
that you guys all already know.
You all know him and
he'll be in the video.
So, see ya.